[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome to
"Talks at Google."
Oh my God, what a crowd.
Amazing.
You are in for a big treat.
If you haven't already seen
"Once On This Island" at Circle
In The Square Theater,
please get it together.
Get your tickets right now.
We'll wait.
Not only is this a revival,
it's a re-imagining of the show.
And we are so excited
to have the cast
and team behind the
show here with us today.
Please give it up.
[APPLAUSE]
Before we kick off
our conversation,
it's my pleasure and honor to
invite Lauren Lott, Quentin
Earl Darrington, Kenita R.
Miller, and Rodrick Covington
to sing "Mama Will Provide."
Please give them a big hand.
[APPLAUSE]
- Hi, everybody.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
[MUSIC - "MAMA WILL PROVIDE"]
RODRICK COVINGTON: (SINGING)
Ti Moune lost all her fear.
She knew Asaka was near.
LOREN LOTT: You never been
away from the sea, child.
You going to need
a helping hand.
A fish has got to
learn to swim on land.
Walk with me, little girl.
Don't you be afraid.
Follow me, little girl.
Let me be your guide.
Oh, a pretty thing like you
will need a thing or two.
And whatever you need,
Mama will provide.
Whoa.
Down the road, little girl, you
may lose your way, all alone
in a world that
may seem too wide.
But sit on Mama's lap,
and I will draw a map.
And whatever you need,
Mama will provide.
I'll provide you moss to soften
the road, rocks to sit on.
ENSEMBLE: Trees.
LOREN LOTT: To sleep underneath.
ENSEMBLE: Sand.
LOREN LOTT: Fun for your toes.
ENSEMBLE: Plantain.
LOREN LOTT: To
fill up your belly.
To fan your face.
Grass, for making your bed.
ENSEMBLE: Mosquitoes.
LOREN LOTT: Ha.
Bugs will bite, little girl,
and the night will fall.
All alone in the dark,
you'll be terrified.
But you will make it through,
because I am liking you.
And whatever you need,
Mama will provide.
Uh-huh, yeah.
ENSEMBLE: Mama will provide.
LOREN LOTT: Hey.
[VOCALIZING]
ENSEMBLE: Mama will provide.
LOREN LOTT: Hey, yeah.
LOREN LOTT: I'm gonna provide.
Walk with me, little girl,
and I'll take you far.
Round each bend, little
friend, I'll be by your side.
That's what a mama's worth,
to give her child the earth.
And whatever you need,
Mama will-- spin your butt
in a circle, just like that.
Oh, Mama will provide.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Keep it going.
One more big round of applause.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
That is how you
start a show, people.
[LAUGHTER]
It is my honor to introduce
the Tony-winning team
behind "Once On This Island."
Please give it up for Lynn
Ahrens and Stephen Flaherty.
[APPLAUSE]
Hello.
LYNN AHRENS: Oh my God.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: OK--
LYNN AHRENS: We never
heard her do that before.
SPEAKER: Miss Loren, we
are going to get to you.
Don't worry.
We're going to talk.
Thank you all so
much for being here.
A big welcome to Google.
Before we get started,
if we could just
go around and quickly
introduce yourself
and your role on the team.
QUENTIN EARL
DARRINGTON: I'm Quentin.
I'm Quentin Earl Darrington.
I play Agwe, the god of water.
KENITA R. MILLER: Hi, my
name is Kenita Miller,
and I play Mama Euralie.
RODRICK COVINGTON:
I'm Rodrick Covington.
I play a storyteller.
KENITA R. MILLER:
You're next, baby.
[LAUGHTER]
LOREN LOTT: I'm Loren
Lott, and I understudy
Ti Moune, Asaka, and Andrea.
Oh.
LYNN AHRENS: I'm Lynn Ahrens.
I wrote the book and
lyrics for the show.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: And
I'm Stephen Flaherty.
I'm the composer of
"Once On This Island."
SPEAKER: Thank you again.
Lynn and Stephen, I'd
love to start with you.
You've been collaborators
since 1982, I think.
Is that right?
LYNN AHRENS: I think '83.
SPEAKER: '83?
STEPHEN FLAHERTY:
Who's counting?
It's been a while.
SPEAKER: How did
you find each other?
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: Well, we
met in a songwriting workshop
here in New York City called the
BMI Musical Theater Workshop.
And I was right off the
bus from the Midwest.
And I had the great good
fortune that I walked in,
and in the class
was Lynn Ahrens.
And I had never collaborated.
I was writing music, book,
and lyrics all myself.
And it was a wonderful,
just chance meeting.
And we just happened
to really hit it off.
And we wrote a
not-very-good song,
but then followed
by a better song,
and then followed
by a better song.
And it's been 30-some years.
SPEAKER: Oh, wow.
And you wrote "Once On
This Island," I think,
something like 27 years ago.
LYNN AHRENS: Yeah.
SPEAKER: How did
this show come about?
What's the origin story?
LYNN AHRENS: Well, when
you do musical theater,
you never can count
on the results.
And so our first show
had gone to Off-Broadway,
a show called "Lucky Stiff"
about a shoe salesman
who takes a dead body on
vacation in a wheelchair.
It was--
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: It
was very dramatic.
LYNN AHRENS: --before
"Weekend at Bernie's."
It was before that.
And you know, it
was Off-Broadway.
It had a limited run.
And we were sort of desperate
to start a next project.
And I went to a
bookstore where they--
remember bookstores?
And they had a used
book shelf, area.
And I pulled a little novel off
the shelf, and I looked at it,
and it had a very colorful
title and colorful cover.
And I opened it up, and
the first words were,
"There is an island
where rivers run deep,
where the sea
sparkling in the sun
earns it the name
Jewel of the Antilles."
The first words on
the page, and I went,
[GASPS] this is a musical.
And I slammed the book
shut, and I ran home.
I bought it for $1.50.
I didn't even haggle.
And I took it home, read it,
and took a cab right over
to Stephen's.
And I said, I think I
found the next show.
So that's how that
happened, yeah.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: I
was just listening
to a lot of world music at
the time, just for pleasure.
Paul Simon had come out
with his seminal record
"Graceland," which
was his voice but it's
filtered through the South
African music of Ladysmith
Black Mambazo.
And I was listening to all that
kind of stuff just for fun.
And I just thought, this
could be a really cool basis
for a theater score
that could have
world music elements in it.
And they never said which
island it was in the book.
So I borrowed a
little from here,
a little from there,
some South American
music, some American gospel.
And I just made it my own.
And it was a fantastic
project to work on.
It was the fastest
writing we had ever done.
We wrote pretty
much the first draft
of the show in six months.
SPEAKER: Oh, wow.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY:
And that's fast.
SPEAKER: What is your process
like in the room together
as collaborators?
Like, do you have
different styles?
How does that work together?
LYNN AHRENS: Well, over
the years, you know,
collaboration-- you're
all collaborators
in one form or another.
And what we've found in all
of these 30-something years
that we've been working together
is that it keeps changing.
So back then, we would sit in
the room every day at a piano,
we would work for
a couple hours,
then we would have Chinese
food, then we would have coffee,
then we would get
over-caffeinated--
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: And Lynn would
say, don't eat the egg roll,
because I would
immediately fall asleep.
[LAUGHTER]
LYNN AHRENS: You know, I got to
know, don't eat the egg roll.
And by the end of the
day, all the tempos
were too fast, because we were
so hyper from a lot of coffee.
And that was then.
And then we gradually, you know,
switched to decaf and salads.
And--
[LAUGHTER]
But the actual working process,
sometimes it's lyrics first.
Sometimes it's music first.
A lot of the time, it's
sort of like a ping pong
match, where he'll go,
do do do do do do do do,
you know, and I'll
say some words.
And I'll get the computer, and
we'll start working together.
And sometimes he'll
email me a tune.
And sometimes I'll
email him lyrics.
In the old days, it was faxing.
Or I would do dramatic readings
on his answering machine.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: Oh,
her dramatic readings
were so great.
She would actually do them in
the voice of the character.
LYNN AHRENS: Yes.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY:
And you know, this
was before email,
and Google, before--
[LAUGHTER]
LYNN AHRENS: It
was before the car.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: Yeah,
but these were so great.
These tapes were great.
They were wonderful.
SPEAKER: Oh, wow.
What's it like to revisit
this show now, in 2018?
LYNN AHRENS: Oh, it's amazing.
I mean, none of you, I'm quite
sure, saw the original in 1990.
But this is
completely different,
this incarnation of the show.
It's almost like night and day.
It's very contemporary.
It's very edgy.
There's real sand,
real fire, real water.
It is set very groundedly in
Haiti after a big disaster.
And it sort of relates not
only to Puerto Rico and all
the disasters in the world
that have ruined and hurt
communities, but has also
brought communities together.
And the concept
of this production
is that the people who've all
been caught in the storm--
out of disaster comes beauty and
community and music and dance
and joy and storytelling.
And it has taken the
show to another place
that we never ever expected.
And to be honest,
at the beginning,
I could not visualize it.
I would come home every night
from our technical rehearsals,
and my husband would
say, how's it going?
And I would say, I have no idea.
I'm sitting in a sandpit,
and it's strewn with garbage,
and there's a goat.
I don't really know
what's happening.
I couldn't see it.
And then little by little,
I began to really, really
understand and appreciate it.
And it's such a beautiful,
special production.
And these guys are unbelievable.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: It's great.
In the first row, they actually
have their feet in the sand.
And the fact that we're doing it
in the round is so revelatory.
I've only seen it in a
proscenium sort of situation,
so this is great,
because it's really
about a dialogue between
the audience and the actors.
And this cast, they
are spectacular.
I mean, each and every one
of them have been handpicked.
And together, they just are
the most joyous community
that you'd ever want to hear.
SPEAKER: Yeah, I mean, I agree.
And I would love to talk to
you all about your involvement
with this show before
this production,
because I know some of
you had done this show.
Kenita, this is--
what number is this?
KENITA R. MILLER: I think
this is maybe the sixth time.
SPEAKER: The sixth time.
KENITA R. MILLER: Yeah.
I said, I'm going
to play Tonton next.
[LAUGHTER]
No, but it's awesome.
I mean, it is kind
of a magical show.
Not kind of, it is.
It's very infectious.
And this production is
my absolute favorite
because of the people.
It's very spoiling.
You don't get to pick who
you work with all the time.
But we have a
great family, which
makes it really easy to kind of
try to recreate that community.
And also, just the elements.
Really, there's a
lot of difficulties
to working in sand,
but there is so much
beauty in working in it, too.
I mean, I take any
opportunity to roll around
in it when I can.
It's like really
playing on the beach.
And as an artist, to have these
actual elements to work with,
all you have to do is
show up and be present,
because it's not much
you have to imagine
as far as the environment.
It's right there.
SPEAKER: I mean, Michael
Arden has a beautiful vision
for this show.
And there are a lot
of the elements,
literally, like
earth, wind, and fire.
You know, hello.
Is that challenging
for you as actors,
to sort of navigate
through that and interact
with those elements, and then--
KENITA R. MILLER: He's in the
water for the whole evening.
He's splashing around.
SPEAKER: Water god, right.
QUENTIN EARL DARRINGTON: I am.
I'm in the water
a good 40%, 50%--
no, maybe more than that.
60%, 70% of the show,
through the entire time.
So since I had to stay in
the water most of the show,
I decided to make the most out
of it and the best out of it.
So I play in the water.
I throw the water.
I splash the water.
You know, I and
the water are one.
So it's a lot a lot of fun.
You said challenging.
I mean, it has some challenges.
It's cold some days.
It's warmer some days.
But I mean, it's fun.
You know, at the end
of the day, it's fun.
So I don't look at it
as a challenge at all.
I look for every single
day is new opportunities,
new blessings, new fun.
So it's fun every single day.
SPEAKER: Loren, we were
talking a little bit backstage.
And you also had an earlier
experience with "Once
On This Island."
Tell us about that.
LOREN LOTT: Yes,
when I was 15, I
was offered the
role of Ti Moune,
and I turned it
down, because I just
thought it was way too big.
So then they had me
do Erzulie instead.
And I was like a fetus Erzulie
among all of these adults.
But that was when I completely
fell in love with this show.
SPEAKER: Oh, wow.
So this is fascinating,
because it's,
in a way, a revisiting
and a re-imagining
for you two, but also for
many of the cast members.
Rodrick, had you had--
did you know about the show?
RODRICK COVINGTON: No, I didn't
know anything about the show.
I mean, I know about Stephen
and Lynn and their work,
but I hadn't seen the show or--
I mean, I heard of the show.
But I hadn't seen
it or anything.
But when we started working
on it, in the reading--
actually, before the reading.
It was when I got material and
just started working on it.
I just fell in love with it.
And I was like, oh my
God, if there's anything
that I want to do in the
next season, it is this.
And I start praying that
I would get the show.
And--
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: I think we
all felt that way, you know?
It just felt like it was
meant to be at this time.
And there's something
about it being very timely.
And from the minute we had
our first meeting with Michael
Arden and Ken
Davenport, our producer,
and our two orchestrators
Michael Starobin and AnnMarie
Milazzo, from that time till--
we said yes.
And then from the
moment of yes to we're
in front of an audience,
it was only a year
and a half, which
is really fast,
because we've been pushing
other shows very slowly along.
But this one, I think
everybody just thought,
this is the time to do this.
And there was an
urgency about it.
SPEAKER: Yeah, I mean, the
show does feel very current.
What was that
decision-making process like?
How did they approach
you about it?
What were the
conversations like?
And why is now a good
time for this show?
LYNN AHRENS: Well, right
now is a great time
for theater, period,
because look where we are.
We need community.
We need to get in the same room.
We need to have dialogue.
That's what theater is.
So you know, our show
feels very topical.
But I think almost
any show feels
very topical at the moment.
Michael Arden is
a genius, I think.
He was an actor to begin with,
and he's an amazing actor
and an amazing singer.
And who knew that he had this
directorial genius in him
as well?
He did a show on Broadway
a few seasons ago
called "Spring Awakening."
It was a revival.
And they did it with the
Deaf West Theatre, right?
And it was all signed,
and it was beautiful.
And when he came to
us, first of all,
he wanted to do
this show a capella.
And we objected to that.
We said, we need a drum.
We need some
musical instruments.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: I just
thought it was going
to be like a doo-wop thing.
I said, is this going to
be like the Pentatonix?
It felt very odd to me.
And I said, you need a drum.
You need this primal drum.
You need a bass.
And then we had
more conversations--
LYNN AHRENS: Yeah, he
brought us drawings.
He started to bring
drawings and show us
visuals that were not exactly
like what we ended up with,
but they implied Haiti.
They implied children.
They implied, you know,
certain magical elements
and fantastical elements and
certain very grim elements
as well.
And what we've
realized along the way
with Michael is--
and we kept saying,
well, that's interesting.
Well, why don't you
go away and bring
us the broomstick
of the Wicked Witch,
and then we'll talk again.
And then he would bring it back.
And we would talk again.
And finally, he won us over.
We thought, this all sounds
good and interesting.
And the whole point
of doing a revival
is to do something different.
The show has been
established in one way,
and why not try to shake it up
and do it in a different way?
So as the authors, it's a big
risk, because "Once On This
Island" gets done all over
the country in schools.
And it's sort of a wonderful,
beloved show, in a way,
for generations of people.
And so to say, OK, you can
bring it back to Broadway,
and we don't quite
understand your concept,
but it sounds really
interesting, was a risk for us.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: The
thing that was exciting,
though, is from the
very first meeting,
he wanted to be
very ritualistic.
He wanted to do it in the round.
He wanted to have the
audience very close
and participating in the story.
And of course, there's only
one Broadway theater that
is in the round, and so there
was no Plan B. So it's like,
either we had to be in Circle
In The Square or not do it.
And I think we just
willed it into being.
We just really imagined it.
And we were fortunate
that they wanted our show,
and we wanted to be there.
SPEAKER: Yeah, I'm
curious about sort
of the process of growing up
with this show, like you did,
Kenita.
We didn't mention this, but
you actually played Ti Moune.
How has your relationship
with this show--
I mean, over 6 times,
has it changed?
Has your understanding of
the characters changed?
KENITA R. MILLER:
Most definitely.
I always joke, I'm
definitely not waiting
for life to begin anymore.
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE] Ti
Moune with a walker.
[LAUGHTER]
But I have fallen in
love with Mama Euralie.
I really have.
One, because I have
aspirations to be a mother,
and I think so that
really speaks to my womb.
And--
LYNN AHRENS: Keep
saying, don't do it yet.
Don't do it yet.
KENITA R. MILLER: And also,
two, this character, it
reminds me of my mother.
And my mom actually did some
missionary work in Haiti.
And she was actually
assigned to orphaned children
and was kind of a part of
putting a school back together.
And so I went back and looked
at a lot of the pictures
that she brought
from-- and it's crazy,
because the uniform that the
little girl wears in the show
is almost identical
to what these kids had
in the photos with my mom.
So I mean, this show has always
been really special to me.
It was one of the first,
because I got started
in musical theater really late.
It was one of the first
shows that I saw myself in.
I saw people that
looked like me.
And the music is infectious,
and the story is, I think--
you know, it has
its own magic to it.
And then putting
it all together,
it's something that I
think a lot of people
hold very dear to them.
And I don't even know if
you, Lynn and Stephen,
if you know what you were
starting when you wrote it.
It really is
something that I think
a lot of-- even if you
don't like theater per se,
it's something that just
really captivates you.
And it has done that to me
since the beginning, yeah.
SPEAKER: I mean, this
is a real treat for me
because this is one of my
favorite Broadway scores
of all time.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: I
gave him $5 to say that.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
Every mention is another five.
My favorite Broadway
score of all time--
[LAUGHTER]
And it was fascinating to hear
while I was preparing for this,
you had had relationships with
some of these marvelous actors.
Quentin and Kenita, you had
actually worked together in--
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: In "Ragtime."
They were Coalhouse and Sarah.
KENITA R. MILLER: First
show ever out of school.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: Was
that your equity card?
KENITA R. MILLER: It was.
It definitely was, yeah.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY:
She was amazing.
We couldn't believe her
the first time we met her.
She's so tiny, and she just
has this enormous voice
and this enormous soul.
And she's incapable of
doing anything false.
LYNN AHRENS: But we
do collect actors.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: She can't.
LYNN AHRENS: We do like actors.
We do.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY:
You also learned
to weed out some of them.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Stay tuned for
the after-show, everybody.
LYNN AHRENS: We'll
tell you later.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: But we
absolutely adore this cast.
And many we've worked with
before, some we haven't.
LYNN AHRENS: Will again.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: Yeah,
and it's so exciting.
You know, you collect them.
SPEAKER: Yes.
Quentin, what's it like to
be back on stage with Kenita?
Is it-- after so many years--
QUENTIN EARL DARRINGTON:
Oh, it's everything.
It's everything.
I actually told my
cast the first day
of one of our workshops--
I walked in the
room, and they asked,
so what is the most
exciting part about today?
Michael Arden asked
us all to say what's
your most exciting part today?
And think of something
you may be the most
trepidatious about today.
And I said, the most
exciting thing about today
is that I get to work
with and hear and see
my favorite singer on Broadway.
And it's Kenita.
From day one-- I've
known Kenita now
since 2001 when we
started "Ragtime" together
with Lynn and Stephen.
So it's been a long time.
And she's been my friend ever
since, and met her husband
the same tour, the
same show, back then.
So I've known the both of
them this whole journey.
So it truly is family, man.
It's the coolest
thing in the world.
It's awesome.
SPEAKER: That's awesome.
Miss Loren, can we talk?
LOREN LOTT: We can talk.
SPEAKER: You know, I
feel like Joan Rivers
up here or something.
[LAUGHTER]
So first of all, that
performance-- just,
please, another
round of applause.
That was--
[APPLAUSE]
Just blown away completely.
And actually, the night
that I was seeing the show,
we saw it with you as Ti Moune.
LOREN LOTT: Oh.
SPEAKER: Yes.
LOREN LOTT: I didn't know that.
You didn't tell me
that this whole time?
SPEAKER: I was like, oh my God.
And you had never
done that song, right?
"Mama Will Provide"?
None of you had ever
seen her do it, right?
LYNN AHRENS: No, we
walked in this morning,
and we said, really?
OK.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: We were told
in the elevator coming up here.
And I'm like, well,
that's going to be fun.
LYNN AHRENS: It's live theater.
You never know.
LOREN LOTT: The struggle.
SPEAKER: The struggle.
So you play a lot of different
roles in the show, Ti Moune,
Asaka, and Andrea.
RODRICK COVINGTON:
She plays everybody.
SPEAKER: Yeah, she plays every--
OK.
LOREN LOTT: Every woman.
SPEAKER: Every woman.
What is it like preparing
for those roles?
I mean, in any given show,
what are you thinking about?
What are you working on?
LOREN LOTT: It's kind of hard to
prepare, because a lot of times
it's really last minute.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
LOREN LOTT: If I'm fortunate
enough to know ahead of time,
each character I feel
like has different needs
and wants different things.
So I try to spend at
least a little bit of time
before that remembering
what they want
and remembering who they
are, because if there's
times when I'm on as
several different people,
then I definitely
will get confused.
But going on for Ti
Moune is probably
the easiest one to go
on for, because she
has a consistent story.
And she's in it the entire time.
And being in the round, you
can just walk into the world.
And then I'm in
the world, so it's
easiest to be focused there.
But usually, I just call my
vocal coach before the shows
and just run it with her when
I know that I'm on as Ti Moune.
I've never gone on for Asaka.
[SIGHS]
[LAUGHTER]
But I know it's coming.
And to prepare for
that, I'll probably
take a really nice
shot of oregano oil,
get my voice ready.
But when I prepare for Andrea, I
just look at a lot of my notes.
And yeah, that's it.
She's mostly ensemble, and
then she's like a character.
So then I just
prepare like that.
But I can't really
prepare like how
you would for a regular
show, because I'm thrown on.
So I don't get to--
I get to focus, but there's
a lot going on when I'm on.
And there's a lot to
remember, because I'm
working with a lot of
people behind the scenes
to help me remember certain
things, like my shoes.
Like, one time I went on, and
they didn't have my shoes.
So I went out barefoot-- which
is fine, we're in the sand--
but it's happened several times.
So then we have to be
communicating backstage.
So there's a lot going on.
So I'm not exactly
as focused as I'd
like to be most of the time.
But I do the job.
LYNN AHRENS: She's unbelievable.
She's like a little
rocket scientist
with all of these charts
and graphs and things.
And she just, she's amazing.
LOREN LOTT: Lynn.
LYNN AHRENS: Pretty
rocket scientist.
SPEAKER: How do you
keep these characters
sort of organized in your head?
I mean, you're memorizing
lines for all three of them.
Is that hard to keep track of?
LOREN LOTT: Well, praise
God, when I was little,
my hobby when I
was doing shows--
because I started
when I was seven,
and then my mom pulled me
out because she was like,
no, I don't want you
to grow up and, like,
you're not going to be able
use the bathroom by yourself
because you're
going to be famous.
And then you're not going to
be able to go to Disneyland
because people are going to
follow you to the bathroom.
So I was like, dang, I want
to go to the bathroom myself.
So I didn't do it.
So I didn't do it
for a long time.
But when I started
at seven, I really
enjoyed memorizing plays.
Like, when I was
in a show, I liked
to know everybody's lines.
And I liked to
memorize everything.
And then it came in handy
because now, doing this show,
I have memorized everybody's
lines and everybody's
everything.
But I keep a lot of notes.
KENITA R. MILLER: Watch out.
LOREN LOTT: I'm
coming for you, Agwe.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: She's
coming after you, Rodrick.
LOREN LOTT: Yeah, Rodrick.
I'm coming for you.
And I keep a lot of videos.
Videos are like my Bible.
I go through my videos
every other night,
and I just try to
remember who's doing what.
But a lot of times,
even when I'm on stage,
I'm watching everybody and
watching everybody who I cover,
trying not to miss anything
so I can stay up to date.
Like, if one character
does something
with another character and
that becomes their thing,
I try to make sure I know
it so that I can come and do
their little, like, thing.
It's always going.
I'm losing it.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: You're hiding it well.
How are you all preparing
for these roles?
I mean, you're on
stage for 90 minutes.
You don't really leave, right?
Do you leave?
I mean, for the most
part, you're there.
QUENTIN EARL DARRINGTON:
No, no, we're
all pretty much all on
stage the whole show.
We leave maybe for a quick
second, then right back out,
all the time.
SPEAKER: I heard Alex talking
about this idea of a snack
track.
Can you tell us what
a snack track is?
And how--
QUENTIN EARL DARRINGTON:
A snack track
is a track in a show where
you may have one song,
and you stay offstage
for most of the show.
So you come on, you kill
it, and then you leave.
I used to consider that to be
like Mufasa in "The Lion King."
Now, I played Mufasa,
and I loved the track.
You sing one song,
and then you die.
And then you stay back
the whole second act.
You're in your
dressing room chilling.
Oh, that's a snack track.
SPEAKER: OK.
And there are no snack
tracks in this show.
QUENTIN EARL DARRINGTON: No.
KENITA R. MILLER: Rodrick
covers Papa Ge, too.
SPEAKER: Oh, really?
OK, tell me about that.
LYNN AHRENS: He's amazing.
LOREN LOTT: It's delicious.
SPEAKER: Oh, I can
see that, yeah.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: Can you see
him as the demon of death?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SPEAKER: You're so sweet, but I
could just see embodying that.
What's that process like?
And how are you creating
that character, but also,
as a storyteller, how are
you-- what's your character
development like?
RODRICK COVINGTON: I mean,
when I first auditioned,
everything was for Papa Ge.
So everything that I was doing
in preparation was for Papa Ge.
And so just going in it, I
just saw myself as Papa Ge.
And I had to adjust more and to
get more into as a storyteller.
And the storyteller is actually
much more work than Papa Ge,
because the storyteller is
constantly on stage and moving
and changing and doing so much.
As Papa Ge, there's
just this one linear--
and I really feel like I was
already prepared for that,
in just the root of it, of
even where Papa Ge comes from,
even just from the voodoo.
And so doing that just honestly
just feels completely right.
You know, I don't ever
get to do that often.
But when I do.
KENITA R. MILLER: It's amazing.
LOREN LOTT: We love it.
KENITA R. MILLER: We
have a woman that plays--
RODRICK COVINGTON: Yeah,
and she's incredible.
LYNN AHRENS: Yeah,
we have a woman
playing the god of death, which
is traditionally a man's role.
And we have a man playing
Asaka, mother of the Earth,
which is traditionally
a woman's role.
So we've shaken up the
genders a little bit
in this production,
which also makes
it really contemporary in
a way and feel unusual.
SPEAKER: Yeah, I want
to talk about that.
I want to open it up to
questions from the audience.
If you want to line up at
the mics on either side,
we'll be happy to
take your questions.
Let's talk about this
nontraditional casting.
First of you, you
all have some really
non-traditional
castmates, live animals.
LOREN LOTT: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: You know, you're
working with goats.
There are chickens in the show.
And I actually heard--
we were talking
a little bit backstage--
a chicken gave birth?
Is this--
KENITA R. MILLER:
They lay eggs now.
LYNN AHRENS: They lay eggs.
RODRICK COVINGTON: Yes.
KENITA R. MILLER: Which is good
It means they're comfortable.
But yeah, we had one lay--
I think it was either
Lorell or Effie.
We have four of
them, and they're all
named after the Dreamgirls.
[LAUGHTER]
And I think it was one of them
actually laid an egg right
there during the pre-show.
So we get fresh organic eggs.
We don't tell them, though.
SPEAKER: Do they get their
own dressing room, or--
KENITA R. MILLER: Oh, yes,
they have their own room
in the back.
They actually have
an animal taxi
that picks them
up from their farm
and takes them to the theater.
SPEAKER: Well, OK.
KENITA R. MILLER:
It's kind of-- yeah.
They've got the life.
They have got the life.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: These
are Broadway chickens.
LYNN AHRENS: They
all have contracts.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: And agents.
SPEAKER: Agents, right.
Take a question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, everyone.
Thank you so much
for being here.
I've seen the show twice.
I love it.
I have a question
about the instruments,
because there's a lot of
interesting instruments.
And I'm curious how those have
changed for this production
than before.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY:
Yeah, originally, we
had a little band
of five people.
So they're like a
little Caribbean band.
But off Michael Arden's
idea of, what if everything
was taken from you?
How would you create music?
How would you tell your story?
We came upon the notion
of actually inventing
some instruments that
are made out of discards,
out of trash, out
of found objects.
And our orchestrator
Michael Starobin
has a good friend named
John Bertles, who has
a group called Bash The Trash.
And that's literally
what they do.
They make instruments
out of trash.
And there's something about
making music or repurposing
something to create a thing
of beauty which we were really
excited about.
So they play all sorts of little
strange and interesting things
throughout the show.
LYNN AHRENS: They whirl tubes
that are actually pitched,
so it's like E-flat,
or whatever it is.
And we have a little girl in
the show-- two little girls,
actually, and they're
both musicians,
very, very talented musicians.
And I love when one of
them is in the show.
And she's a cellist.
And she plays a little cello,
but it's made out of, I think,
a cardboard box and some
strings and wires and stuff.
And it's just adorable, you
know, and it actually plays.
So it's all that.
Glass Coke bottles and
all sorts of good stuff.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY:
So we still have
our little combo,
little island band,
but with the trash instruments.
And also, we were experimenting
with the idea of, instead
of using synth pads
like we did originally,
creating those textures
with the human voice.
LYNN AHRENS: Voices.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: And so we have
a beautiful vocal arrangement
that functions as part of
the orchestration, created
by AnnMarie Milazzo, who did
all the vocal work on "Spring
Awakening."
And she's wildly inventive.
And they're amazing that
they can execute this stuff,
because it's tricky.
LYNN AHRENS: And all that's
new in this production.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY:
It's all new, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Wonderful.
Thank you.
SPEAKER: What's it
like to hear the music
with those sort of found
objects and instruments?
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: Well,
you know, the whole thing
was a big process
of experimentation.
I think there's something about
going into a revival where you
know that the show itself works,
so it actually frees you up
to try a lot more other things.
And this is one of the things.
And it was sort of like a-- we
had a series of small workshops
where we had experiment
with these vocals
and then these ideas
for the instruments.
And using the voice, it actually
makes the show more human,
because actually, it's
different voices supporting
the other voices.
And there's something about
that that just grabs you.
SPEAKER: Great Let's take
a question over here.
AUDIENCE: I've loved this
score for a long time,
listened to the
soundtrack many times
and waited many
years for a revival.
And this one was amazing.
But I always thought that maybe
it wasn't revived on Broadway
because it's short.
It's a one-act.
Was I right about that?
And if I was, did you ever
consider making it longer?
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: I don't
think it was the length.
LYNN AHRENS: I don't think
it was the length either.
Go ahead.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: It
seems like these days,
theater pieces want
to get shorter,
and movies are just
getting longer, you know?
I mean, movies are so long now.
But I don't think that
that was ever an issue.
I know when we took it to
London, the London people,
they like that full night out.
And they said, can't we create--
LYNN AHRENS: Can't
we go to the bar?
STEPHEN FLAHERTY:
Can't we go to the bar?
Can't we create-- and
we said, no, it really
doesn't want a break.
So what they did is they
ripped apart the theater,
and they made it into
a Caribbean village.
And they had all
sorts of Caribbean--
LYNN AHRENS: Goat pies.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: --goat
pies and Caribbean bands
playing after.
So they had like an
after-show kind of thing.
So it was like you could
just hang and do that.
LYNN AHRENS: I think
it's just taken this long
because it's just taken
this long, you know?
I don't think there's any
real reason other than it just
takes somebody to fall
in love with something
and have a vision for it and
say, I want to bring this back.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: There was
always talk about revivals,
but I'm glad it didn't happen
until now, because I think
we needed to wait for
the right group of people
to manifest themselves and
sort of show up in time.
AUDIENCE: Great
LYNN AHRENS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for coming to Google.
This question is
mainly for Lynn,
because I was really
struck by how you mentioned
the importance of community and
the arts bringing us together.
I work on YouTube, so I'm always
very curious and excited when
creators come in.
How do you think that
YouTube specifically, maybe
Google in general,
could do a better
job of supporting the arts and
engaging those conversations
through our online platforms?
LYNN AHRENS: Uh-oh.
Well--
[LAUGHTER]
I think you do a great
job to begin with.
Years ago, I wrote
songs and sang
for a show called "Schoolhouse
Rock," which maybe some of you
grew up with.
And they're all on YouTube.
And so I can see my life
flashing before my eyes
sometimes, you know?
And it's extraordinary to me
how you can find so many things
on there and through Google.
I mean, almost the knowledge
of the world at our fingertips.
And I love that.
I don't know how you
could do a better job.
But maybe-- is there
a theater channel
in your future or something?
You know, live performance
is very ephemeral.
You see it one night, and
Alex Newell is playing Asaka.
You see it the next
night, and Loren Lott
is playing Asaka because
Alex got ill or whatever.
You know, one night
an actor is on,
the next night
they're not as good
because they're not feeling
as well or whatever it is.
So to capture live theater,
I think, is very important.
And the more we can do
that, within legal limits,
the better.
There's a lot of
stuff on YouTube
that people sort of hold the
camera up and then stick it
under their coat or something.
And we don't want that so much.
But maybe there's
something in that idea.
I don't know how you
would do your job better.
I feel I'm in the heart
of technology right now.
It's like the
belly of the beast.
It's really cool.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: There's
something really exciting,
though, about the idea
of global community,
because that really didn't
exist before the advent
of the internet and all of that.
LYNN AHRENS: That's right.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: I find that
that's potentially really
exciting, just the idea
of that interfacing.
LYNN AHRENS: Yes, exactly.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thank you so much.
LYNN AHRENS: Thank you.
Thanks for asking that.
SPEAKER: Quentin, we
were talking a little bit
about craft and sort
of learning your craft
and honing your craft.
What's your perspective on the
whole sort of digital landscape
as it relates to young
artists coming up?
Obviously, a lot of people
getting discovered on YouTube.
What's your
relationship with that?
What's your perspective on it?
QUENTIN EARL DARRINGTON:
It's interesting,
because in this age
of social media,
things are so, so, so, so fast.
Information moves so fast.
We learn so fast, which,
honestly, at a lot of times
makes audience members'
attention spans shorter.
And just like we said with shows
getting shorter and shorter
and shorter, these quick
blurbs, these quick things.
Not too many people
are taking the time
to read as much anymore
or to take the time
to really sit through a three
and 1/2 hour production.
I hear "Angels in
America" is back.
And it's an event,
which I can't wait
to see and to be a part of.
I think there's
some pros and cons
to the way this
push has happened
for us all moving forward.
But I hope that
there's a happy medium
that we can continue to find,
artistically, creatively,
and for our human nature and
growth all across the board,
to keep growing and producing
great art and great people.
SPEAKER: Yeah, Loren, you
were on "American Idol."
You've done a lot
of film and TV work,
but we're talking a
lot about live theater.
What's it like being
back in the theater?
Do you prefer one
over the other?
What are the differences?
LOREN LOTT: I go back and
forth, because sometimes I
prefer theater.
But I prefer theater when
I'm working on TV and film.
And then when I'm
working on TV and film,
I feel like I
prefer TV and film,
because there is something
really nice about doing
one scene, and then
if I mess it up,
just doing it over
and over again,
and then going back to
my trailer and napping.
And then crafties, which,
when you're on a set,
there's food everywhere.
And it's called crafties.
And they become
your best friends.
Or they become my best friends.
But I love that.
I love crafties.
Because in theater,
I remember during
our first few rehearsals, I
hadn't done theater in a while.
And I was like, so
where's crafties?
[LAUGHTER]
And Alex Newell laughed at me.
And then we became friends.
But I think right now, theater
like this, in our worlds--
because I feel
like we're actually
in our own little world, and
it's really, really special.
And it's really different than
any other show that I've done.
So right now I prefer the
round, prefer theater.
SPEAKER: Yeah, one of the last
songs in the show, or actually
the last song, is "Why
We Tell the Story."
Can you talk a little bit about
why you all tell the story
and what the show means to you?
RODRICK COVINGTON: Well, I
have 18 brothers and sisters
in Florida.
My parents had 19 kids.
And I have over 150
nieces and nephews
because all of my siblings
have kids except my brother
and I, who are
the 18th and 17th.
And then their kids have
kids and kids and kids.
And so it really is a village,
and like our community
and tribe.
And so every time that
we get to that part,
and the little girl
reminds us of the story,
my heart wells up
every time because I
think of my nieces
and my nephew,
particularly Tyra and Tory,
and just how my life right now
has to be about them.
You know what I mean?
And no longer about me, because
it's about the next generation.
And that's why I tell the story.
And that's why I'm
so grateful that I
feel an alignment
of being a part
of this particular
production, because it's
about the next generation.
KENITA R. MILLER:
I tell the story
because I have to, and for
similar reasons, but also
to not to forget.
We say, hope is why,
faith is why, love is
why, grief is why, pain is why.
And I think that they
are all emotions that
make us so beautifully human.
And it's OK to feel
all of those things
and actually is
what connects us.
And we have strength
in our emotions.
as being a human being.
And so I think when I
think of all those words
and why they're
important, it always
comes down to making me
remember how resilient we
are when we come together
and when we allow ourselves
to live in our humanity.
SPEAKER: What have
the fans' reactions
to the show been like?
You're obviously interacting
with the audience
during the show.
But have you heard from fans?
Do you hear from them a lot?
I can imagine-- Loren,
do you want to--
LOREN LOTT: Oh, yeah.
SPEAKER: Or Lynn.
LOREN LOTT: Yeah.
I definitely-- I think we
all have our own experiences
with supporters.
But me being an understudy,
I didn't really expect much.
I expected to be
supporting everybody else
while they are being supported.
But the younger audience,
especially on social media,
they'll draw pictures.
Or every time that I'm on
as a different character,
if I post it and they
haven't seen it before,
they'll draw pictures,
or they'll send letters.
I just received some "Once On
This Island" custom shoes that
someone--
some Nikes that someone made.
Yeah.
And I also, I'm always
posting that I love hot sauce.
So sometimes when
people come to the show,
they'll bring me goodie bags.
And it'll have candy in it or
a nice letter and hot sauce.
And I have received
a lot of hot sauce.
And it's filling up in my room.
And everyone judges me,
but it's just like--
it makes me so happy that
people give me hot sauce.
People actually hear
me and they see me
and then they get excited.
People are always asking
me about my Ti Moune
dates and stuff, and they
try to plan around when
to come back based off of that.
And it just makes me feel
really, really special.
SPEAKER: Hot sauce, everyone.
Please bring some.
LOREN LOTT: [INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER: Lynn, did you
want to say something.
LYNN AHRENS: No,
I mean, that's--
they don't bring me hot sauce.
LOREN LOTT: Yet.
LYNN AHRENS: And when I
come out of the theater,
there's always this
huge line of fans
waiting for all these guys.
And I just sneak
out the other way,
and nobody has a clue
who the writers are.
Nobody ever does.
But what we do get as writers
is people come up to us and say,
I got married to "The Human
Heart," or that sort of thing.
Or one woman said she gave birth
to "Waiting for Life to Begin,"
which I thought--
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: Really?
Are you serious?
LYNN AHRENS: I swear.
Was hilarious to me.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: Did she
put it on a loop tape?
LYNN AHRENS: I don't know.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: Or did
she do it in, like, three
and 1/2 minutes?
LYNN AHRENS:
[WORDLESS SINGING] Push.
I don't know how she did it.
But we hear a lot from
people who saw the original
and are knocked
out by the revival.
They had no idea.
Or a lot of people who
never saw the original,
like probably your
age, who have grown up
with the album, the original
album, and are coming to see it
and saying, oh my God, I just
never visualized it like this.
It's so stunning.
So we hear from a lot of people.
We do.
SPEAKER: Wow.
QUENTIN EARL DARRINGTON:
You guys have, like,
the best cafes and food here.
And when we were
just eating lunch,
Loren asked for hot sauce.
She was on a mission to
find some over there.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: Official
Google hot sauce, right?
QUENTIN EARL DARRINGTON:
Official Google.
It's in the Google vision.
SPEAKER: It's the Google vision.
Before we close-- we're going
to close with two songs--
I want to play a quick game with
you all, if you're up for it.
LYNN AHRENS: OK.
QUENTIN EARL DARRINGTON: Yeah.
SPEAKER: So we're going to
play a version of the Proust
questionnaire.
This is from the 1880s.
It's since been
updated for this talk.
But we're just going to
popcorn around, ask questions.
Feel free to answer with the
first thing that comes to mind.
And just pass the mics around.
Sound good?
QUENTIN EARL DARRINGTON: Yes.
SPEAKER: OK, great.
What is your greatest
extravagance?
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: This is me?
SPEAKER: Anyone.
Anyone--
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: Hot sauce.
[LAUGHTER]
LOREN LOTT: I like
where this is going.
LYNN AHRENS: We just go around?
Cabs.
QUENTIN EARL DARRINGTON: Food.
Food.
KENITA R. MILLER: Take-out.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: Extravagance?
KENITA R. MILLER: Hey.
That's a yes, that
takes a lot of my money.
SPEAKER: Seamless is a luxury.
OK, go-to audition song.
RODRICK COVINGTON:
"Feeling Good."
KENITA R. MILLER:
"God Bless the Child."
QUENTIN EARL DARRINGTON:
I don't have one.
SPEAKER: Word or
phrase you overuse.
LOREN LOTT: Oh my gosh.
LYNN AHRENS: That she does.
[LAUGHTER]
RODRICK COVINGTON: Chillax.
SPEAKER: Chillax.
QUENTIN EARL DARRINGTON:
That's what's up.
SPEAKER: That's what's up.
Cast album you
play in the shower.
LOREN LOTT: "Rain."
LYNN AHRENS: "Singing
in the Rain."
SPEAKER: Ooh.
LOREN LOTT: I play
"Rain" in the shower.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: I actually
listen to Alex Newell's Spotify
channel on my shower.
SPEAKER: Yes.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY: It gets you
going in the morning, yeah.
SPEAKER: Check him out
on Google Play, everyone.
[LAUGHTER]
Right.
STEPHEN FLAHERTY:
I said the S-word.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Role you've
always wanted to play.
KENITA R. MILLER: Eartha Kitt.
SPEAKER: Eartha Kitt.
KENITA R. MILLER: Yeah.
RODRICK COVINGTON: [INAUDIBLE].
LYNN AHRENS: Betty Comden.
LOREN LOTT: Mufasa.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Yes.
OK, we're going
to end on Mufasa.
Please give them all a big hand.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you all so much.
And please welcome back Quentin
Earl Darrington to sing "Rain."
And he will be followed
by Miss Loren Lott singing
"Waiting For Life."
Please keep it going for them.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, yeah, that's perfect.
[MUSIC - "RAIN"]
QUENTIN EARL DARRINGTON:
(SINGING) Let there be no moon.
Let the clouds race by.
Where the road meets the
sea, let the tide be high.
Let there be a girl
walking by the sea.
And let there be rain, rain.
Listen to her prayers,
full of hope and pain
as she stares down the
road in the pouring rain.
Rain on the road.
Rain on her face.
Rain makes a road such
a dangerous place.
Let there be a car,
racing through the night.
Where the road meets
the sea, let her wait.
the sea, let him spin.
Where the road meets
the sea, let their fate
begin in the rain.
Rain.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE] Quentin
Earl Darrington, everybody.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
OK, now please welcome
back Loren Lott
to sing "Waiting For Life."
[APPLAUSE]
LOREN LOTT: Sheesh.
[MUSIC - "WAITING FOR LIFE"]
(SINGING) A stranger
in white in a car,
going somewhere, going far.
How it must feel to go
racing wherever you please,
flying as free as a bird
with its tail in the breeze.
Even the fish in the sea
must be longing to fly,
catching a glimpse of the
stranger in white racing by.
Oh gods, oh gods, are you there?
What can I do to get you
to look down and give in?
Oh gods, oh gods,
hear my prayer.
I'm here in the field
with my feet on the ground
and my fate in the air,
waiting for life to begin.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Mama's contented and Tonton
accepts what he gets,
happy for tea in their cups
and no holes in their nets,
happy to have what they have
and to stay where they are.
They never even look up
at the sound of a car.
A stranger racing down the
beach, racing to places
I was meant to reach.
My stranger, one
day you'll arrive.
Your car will stop, and in
I'll hop, and off we'll drive.
We'll drive.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Oh gods, oh gods,
please be there.
Don't you remember your
little Ti Moune from the tree?
Wake up.
Look down.
Hear my prayer.
Don't single me out
and then forget me.
Oh gods, oh gods, let me fly.
Send me to places where
no one before me has been.
You spared my life.
Show me why.
You get me to rise like
a fish to the bait,
then tell me to wait.
Well, I'm waiting,
waiting for life to begin.
Waiting for life to begin.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER: Keep it going.
[APPLAUSE]
Get your tickets and go
see "Once On This Island"
at Circle In The Square Theater.
Thank you all for being here.
Have a good day.